the countdown is on to next Saturday's
Royal Wedding of Britain's Prince Harry
and Megan Markel and what's a wedding
without a cake
it's been a tradition to serve royal
wedding guests fruitcake including the 9
foot tall 500 pound confection baked for
Queen Elizabeth's 1947 nuptials but
Harry and Megan continue to break the
mold not only will their cake be
different but so will the Baker who like
the bride is from the United States when
a member of the royal family gets
married every announcement makes news
including who's baking the wedding cake
after Prince Harry and Los Angeles
native Megan Markel selected Claire
Pataki the news rippled across the pond
with Newsweek asking who is Claire Batac
when we first met attack in 2015 the
American Baker was a rising star in
London two and a half years later she's
become baking royalty
Kensington Palace tweeted the news back
in March saying Prince Harry and miss
Marcal have asked Claire to create a
lemon elderflower cake that will
incorporate the bright flavors of spring
my first love was baking how did that
happen
well my mother is a great Baker my
grandmother's a great Baker and where I
grew up in Inverness which is just north
of San Francisco it's rural and we had
wild blackberries and apple trees and so
there was a lot of emphasis on baking
with fruit that was in season potox
spent three years as a pastry chef for
Alice Waters at Chez Panisse in Berkeley
California she then moved to London to
be with her boyfriend now husband this
was like okay I just came from something
really great I've got to make this
really great otherwise I'm gonna be
totally diverse so she set up a stall in
a weekend market in East London's
Hackney neighbourhood baking everything
in her home kitchen I realized you know
it was kind of taking over our lives and
what made you take that leap to open the
bakery
my husband was just like get out of the
house she opened her bake shop violet in
2010 her unique recipes and fresh
ingredients would catch the eye of
London elite like Nigella Lawson Jamie
Oliver and apparently a prince from
London and future Duchess from Hollywood
I am so excited for Clare attack that is
such a great assignment and they know no
pressure or anything I mean terrifying
right but boy has she earned it and that
stuff her bakery is incredible oh man
you should have brought us in bad couple
years ago we ate it all up